los ejércitos de Corea del Sur y Estados
Unidos han respondido hoy al misil
lanzado el martes por Corea del Norte
disparando sus propios misiles Y ante
todo anunciando el retorno a aguas de la
Península coreana de un portaaviones
estadounidense de propulsión nuclear el
martes pyongyang disparó un misil
balístico de Rango intermedio que
sobrevoló territorio japonés por primera
vez desde 2017 y que de hecho es el
proyectil norcoreano que más distancia
ha recorrido jamás tras volar en torno a
unos 4.500 kilómetros antes de caer al
océano Pacífico hoy las tropas
surcoreanas y estadounidenses han
disparado cuatro misiles tierra Tierra
de corto alcance y han anunciado después
que el portaaviones Ronald Reagan que
hace una semana precisamente se
encontraba en la Península coreana
realizando maniobras con la marina de
Japón y de Corea del Sur retornará ahora
a la zona para dar respuesta a la acción
norcoreana los expertos creen que el
régimen de Kim Jong Está tratando de
forzar esta respuesta por parte de los
aliados y creen que en el Horizonte se
divisa ya con Claridad la posibilidad de
una nueva prueba nuclear por su parte
los satélites han mostrado que Corea del
Norte lleva lista desde hace meses para
realizar un nuevo testatómico pero los
analistas creen que esta prueba no
llegaría antes de que concluya el
congreso del partido comunista chino que
arranca dentro de 10 días de Cara a no
soliviantar a Pekín el principal socio
comercial de Corea del Norte